[Music]
foreign
right
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm retiring well in that case what are
we drinking same for the goddaughter God
told me you found something on a train
during the war a dial that could change
the course of history why are you
chasing the thing that drove your father
crazy
he'll move please get out of here
sorry
[Music]
Jones get him
Hitler made mistakes and with this I
will correct them all you stole it then
you stole it and then I stole it it's
called capitalism
thank you
seat belt there might be some tablets
you've taken your chances made your
mistakes
and now a final Triumph
[Music]
Indiana Jones two times in my life we're
seeing things
I'm going to torture with Voodoo
been shot nine times
included once by your father
sorry
well I've been looking for this
all my life
[Music]